terror en guayaquil los narcos
evolucionan sus métodos disparos y una
fuerte explosión resultado muertos
heridos y desaparecidos también ocho
casas destruidas el presidente guillermo
lasso anunció medidas en twitter he
declarado en estado de excepción a la
ciudad de guayaquil debido a los sucesos
delictivos dados en las últimas horas se
dispondrá de toda la fuerza pública para
restablecer el control de la ciudad no
permitiremos que el crimen organizado
pretenda manejar al país el suceso tuvo
lugar en el barrio del cristo del
consuelo a las dos de la madrugada una
moto lanzó una bolsa con explosivos y
sintió muy fuerte fue yo pensé que era
que estaba temblando en la tierra lo
primero porque o sea la cama se movió un
remezón y esto sí yo cogí amigo lo jale
con angustia el bebé y me iba a salir
corriendo como loca pero me calme ya y
me quedé y ahí dice aunque no queda bien
la medida que había tirado en la calle 8
la policía investiga y busca información
ofrecen 10 mil dólares de recompensa
desde el primer atentado con explosivos
contra civiles
se degrada día a día y se va de mal en
peor
se ha multiplica la situación
guayaquil vive a una ola de violencia
por el control del narcotráfico es el
epicentro de américa latina- para la
exportación de cocaína la tasa de
homicidios por 100.000 habitantes en
ecuador ha pasado de 6 a 14 desde 2018
el reflejo de la situación se ve en las
prisiones donde más de 350 personas han
sido asesinadas en disputas entre bandas